[Music]
now I am going to be camping only using
this axe but I want my boys actually
have a good time and want to come back
with me so I got them some bed rolls and
some some basic supplies so they're
gonna have a little bit more luxury and
comfort on this trip and while I I rough
it a bit you like your bed roll Tom it's
gonna drop 2030 degrees tonight and get
a little bit windy so we really better
get a shelter or it's gonna be a very
very cold night especially since I don't
have a bag or a bed roll or any of that
all right let me show you my survival
axe it's a fist car ax with a 36 inch
handle I'll put a link in the
description and I've wrapped a handle in
about a hundred feet of paracord using a
chain Sinnott not it's nice an ergonomic
looks good and then you can just go and
pull the string and quick deploy all the
paracord out if you need i've also
wrapped about a couple hundred feet of
really high-quality fishing line around
the handle here inside the handle i've
stored a few goodies as well yeah so
there's a little string here
pull the string alright so let me show
you what i had stored in the handle of
the axe got a flint and steel a fishing
lead and i've got a bunch of snailed
fishing hooks got some cotton balls for
starting fires
I've got three packets of this
chlorophyll och a chemical you put in
water to chlorinate it and then I've got
a slightly chewed up banged up space
blanket here so using just the supplies
that were inside my axe handle I'm gonna
try to find some food and camp for the
night
alright alright buddy here's your
canteen I see so this isn't like an army
canteen and this is a pot for cooking so
in your bedroll you've got hand warmers
canteen a pot two flashlights and a
little extra water I got stuff for baked
potatoes ramen oozes steak and don't
know why because we need it let's see
yes yeah I think this is where I'm gonna
sleep tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys take that over
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know the weather's not too bad today
it's just the wind cold wind is just
gonna kill us so this shelter all it's
really doing is just keeping us out of
the wind it's a pretty decent windbreak
alright we're gonna add the chlorophyll
on here
you can see that Clara phlox done its
trick there's little piles of sediment
and goobers on the bottom it not only
does it chlorinate and and protect the
water from viruses but it makes a lot of
the solids flocculate or become solids
and sink to the bottom so it makes it a
little cleaner tastes better too
that tasted good I needed that water
well I'm hoping I can catch some fish
for my dinner tonight but first I'm
gonna need some bait
so let's there we go yeah look at that
that's some good bait right there let me
see the worms we're gonna take I'm gonna
take some of this dirt and here watch it
yeah there's the worms
some of them we got your boot yes there
are worms in your boot all right we got
the worms in a plastic bag I've got to
go and seal this up and put it somewhere
cold and damp or they're gonna die
that's all the fishing line so I've got
two hot circle hook and a two-out
sliding lead here throw some worms on
this it'll be perfect for catfish so
worms well there we go
I got a bunch of worms on the catfish
hook see if we can catch something well
this is a good a spot as any but I
really just don't want to snag up my
line i if I snag up my line that's it I
lose all my fishing gear sure hope I
don't put this in the trees just snapped
just like that
holy crap well losing that hook was a
bit of a kick in the stomach it looks
like I'm going to be going vegan tonight
if it was a little later in the year and
the bluegill we're in the shallows I
would make a fish gouge which is like a
little wooden sliver that you use like a
fishing hook use those in the past but
the bluegill aren't here so I'm gonna
have to forge my way out of this problem
hey guys here's something right here
right here see see these long leaves
right here all right so this is filled
garlic right here it looks just like
chives or garlic stems but smaller and
you can't miss it the smell is just like
garlic very hard to get wrong and it's
delicious and this will go perfect on
Tommy's baked potatoes tonight so we're
gonna gather up a bunch of this let's
see if we can find some more filled
garlic I'll leave that oh good oh good
[Music]
yeah look at that
got the whole thing let's dig it up try
to get the whole plant
yeah because meagerly you going to pull
those apart Tommy that is a pile of
garlic you guys to show me you garlic
yeah look at that put them in there wash
it up you might need to change your
water a couple times look at that pile
of pile of garlic right there I need
some tubers something of substance I
can't just eat leaves I need like roots
so we're gonna look for arrow Arab okay
what we're looking for is the tuber of a
plant called arrow Arum the Leafs are
mildly toxic like poison ivy
however the tubers are edible so we're
gonna find arrow arrow reverse an arrow
Arum is a marshy plant that lives right
on the edge of the water you can see the
waters a little bit low right now and
you'll see green shoots coming up AHA
right here okay this right here are the
shoots of the arrow arrow just beginning
to sprout so there's tubers down there
all right guys ready to dig those up oh
I broke off part of it you can see there
there's part of the tube there we go I
found dinner we'll take these and let's
go get some more there's some right here
oh well that's a big one I got you now
oh oh look at that my Hema the head back
cooking some dinner
what'd you guys make your own for you
know that's actually really slick cuz
the trees on the wind side so man
that'll actually work pretty good if you
guys got lost in the woods an escape
hatch
alright guys there we go I have never
worked so hard for a vegetable in my
life I love hanging out with you oh I've
got so much mud and grime underneath my
fingernails my fingernails just hurt so
bad
there's so many unknown things about
eating these wild vegetables I know the
tubers edible I know the green parts
poisonous where does the edible part
stop and the poison part begin I don't
know we're gonna find out
yeah thing am i allergic to this who
knows I may have a super freaky reaction
to this I have no clue we're gonna find
out it's a I wouldn't recommend doing
this honestly you know how work it's so
hard for this and it's not like it's
Krispy Kreme doughnuts you know it's not
the best tasting thing in the world yeah
I gotta wash my GoPro well there we go
that is the fruit of my Labor's and it's
a lot more tubers that I actually
thought there's gonna be all right there
we go kind of cleaned up there's one
doing this with a potato peeler or even
a pocketknife would be so much easier
hold as many of these tubers as you can
okay yeah back to the camp take that
back to the camp lay it on your blanket
yeah cotton balls they like to burn
Nathan what's the matter with your hands
yes
take the mud rub it back and forth in
between your fingers like so well I had
Nathan grab some of those tubers and
help me haul him back to the the
fireside and a few minutes later he
started complaining that his hands were
itching so he's definitely having a
reaction to these tubers so that's kind
of the danger of eating these wild foods
man you don't know how you're gonna
react you know my hands are doing okay
but you know you might want to be real
careful before we eat these your hands
feeling better
well washing them with mud seemed to
help didn't it that your pocket knife
from Scotland so what are we doing
you're making a stick to go and cook
your meat put a little pressure and push
it away from you well my space blankets
gonna be very useful tonight so I better
drink my fill dry it off and get ready
to use it tonight the clone flock is
done really well all the dirt that's
settled down in the bottom it's really
clean water now these blankets are so
usable they can be used as heat
reflectors tarps to keep the rain off or
something to keep you warm they got a
dry mine off and it's gonna do any good
tonight you guys hungry huh I bet you
are it's been a long day okay you're
ready for some steak no pepper
we got a bunch of baked potatoes for you
guys go ahead and cook those up you
loving your cup of noodle I'll get good
yep that's good it's ready buddy that
good buddy awesome
enjoy your food
don't mind me guys I'll just sit over
here with my tubers and you enjoy your
steak that is done Tom you tear that out
I love you too buddy
you take a baked potato and you shove it
under your coat and keep you warm and
then once it cools down then you eat it
you guys warm so far
you know those tubers make me nervous
there's a lot of unknowns about eating
wild food like this so I'm gonna boil it
really good before I eat it and see if
that doesn't help a little bit and to do
that I'm gonna cheat a little bit and
steal uh Nathan's pot so it's my one
cheat so far all right I boiled the tar
out of it and it looks kind of like taro
root really is the consistency of boiled
taro root you know if you've ever had
poi over in Hawaii or something it's
kinda kind of looks like that
all right guys moment of truth hope and
I boiled all the poison of this thing
and if I didn't I'll know about it real
quick cuz it doesn't take very long for
your mouth start burning if you bite
into the leaves or stem of this plant
but uh all right let's give it a go
might be edible but it's not delicious
so I'm gonna go ahead and crush up these
garlic bulbs and put it in there so I
can get a little bit of flavor in this
thing
a little campfire grit for texture
little garlic for flavor man I liked
what the boys were eating better well
I'm eating it but it's like eating a
glue stick with a hint of garlic not
it's not very pleasant and um every once
in a while there's just this little
tinge of something on the back of my
tongue a little weirdness there it's
like there's a few uncooked pieces
floating around in there it's definitely
a survival food not a food you eat for
fun well I ate it and it wasn't great
but there's definitely kind of a weird
burning aftertaste kind of like if
you've eaten something really spicy a
while ago and then just kind of that
lingering burn in your mouth it's not
bad but it's just kind of there I
wouldn't I wouldn't recommend eating
this outside of a survival situation and
you never know what eating large
quantities of it will do to you so I
think a few mouthfuls is about all I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go to bed hungry
tonight
this spider just jumped on my hand I
don't know where he came from come on
my socks are so wet so I'm barefoot
right now and I'm really think that's
gonna make things unpleasant but we're
gonna keep this fire going slow and low
and and just I think we'll be okay
well it's about 1:00 in the morning and
it's got a little cold out but this
space blankets actually helping a lot
but I'm gonna stoke the fire and try to
get some more sleep well the sun's about
to rise it's a little before 7:00 in the
morning good morning guys how'd you
sleep
Nathan you amaze me how well you sleep
in cold weather like I can't count how
many times Tommy stole the blanket from
Nathan and he was just sitting there
with no blanket snoozing away
well guys did you have fun yeah yeah we
did so we're gonna get the fire out
we're gonna roll up our bed rolls and
we're gonna get ahead of home
you ready to break down the fort put it
all back the way we found it time to go
home guys ready to see mama yeah I'm
excited to see mama too if you liked
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like that
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell fight
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching